Today we are going to create imaginary
characters and make them dance. And we’ll
use an AI to greatly improve the details
in low-quality streamed gaming videos,
and we will see if it is possible for a
robot to learn to smell. Spoiler alert:
there is a new AI that has no nose,
and yet it can still smell. Kind of.
Now, this is an AI paper from 2016. This
is what was possible 8 years ago. You could
take a source video of an amazing dancer,
and take a video of yourself moving about,
and then, it would transfer
these amazing dance moves to you.
But today, not only text to image, but text to
video is getting more and more available. This
means that you just enter a piece of text, and
out comes a video of exactly that. What’s more,
today, you can do this with free and open
source techniques. But if that is possible,
does that mean that? Yes, yes it does!
So now, hold on to your papers Fellow
Scholars, because today, we have come so far,
you don’t even need a video of yourself.
Just a little stick figure moving about,
and one text prompt to synthesize the video.
And then, a character of you will start dancing.
Wow - look at how far we have come in the last few
years. These new results are still not perfect,
but they are leaps and bounds beyond the Everybody
Dance Now paper. And this is not only better,
but it also solves a significantly more difficult
problem. You see, here, with your text prompt you
can choose your background and your attire
as you wish. No video of you is needed.
But, it gets better. If you can use a text
prompt, you can write whatever you want there,
even the Mona Lisa, or any other character
you can think about. A couple years ago,
we were happy if we got a text to image result
with this, and now, we can just make them up,
and make them move around exactly the
way we want it to. Absolutely incredible.
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Now I will quickly note that this paper is a
tech report, and as of the making of this video,
it was not peer reviewed yet. It just
came out a few days ago, and supposedly,
the source code and the datasets for
creating all this will also be available.
Now, we talked about a brilliant little paper
earlier where scientists at NVIDIA wanted
to create high-quality videoconferencing
videos by compressing them down far more
than previously thought possible.
Now I could tell you what it does,
but I will tell you what it does not - it does not
compress the entirety of the video information,
but it only takes the first image from the
video, and they throws away the entire video
afterwards! What? Why? It is able to do it because
it learns about your head movement and gestures,
and is able to synthesize that in a
way that is super close to reality.
That is fantastic. However, look. Compression
artifacts still remain. The lower we go with the
bandwidth, the worse it gets. And now, you
can use their newer technique to eliminate
those. Look. When streaming games or video,
unless you have a really fast connection,
you get some of these. Artifacts along these
lines, and something perhaps even worse,
blocky artifacts. But now, with these new
super resolution AI techniques, ha! No more.
Look at that flag. If you wanted
to get this kind of quality,
you would either need a significantly more
powerful internet connection to stream it,
or an expensive computer to render it
yourself. Once again, no more. Love it.
Now, not even this technique is perfect, its
earlier version was widely tested, and testers
typically found it to be working really well
on static and slow-moving content. However,
when used on fast moving footage, it might
introduce its own artifacts. Now to the best
of my knowledge, it is already available on
the RTX 2000 series graphics cards and up,
which is fantastic news, these are from an age
when these cards were a little more affordable.
More longevity for us. I like it. Note that
we do not have any business ties with NVIDIA.
And now, the ultimate question, Fellow
Scholars. We know that these modern AI
techniques learned to listen, see, and
even talk. But here is a crazy question:
is it possible for an AI to learn to smell?
Well, this crazy paper attempts to give this
a try. First, they give it a bunch of molecule
structures as an input, and they get information
on what humans think this smells like. For
instance, this molecule structure smells like
a musty research paper with a hint of caramel.
And then, the goal is that we give it
new compounds that it hasn’t seen yet,
excuse me hasn’t smelled yet. So, what did it
learn? Well, it learned how we label these smells,
and now hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
because when given these molecule structures,
it can tell them apart at least as well
as a human can. That is mind-blowing.
Now just to avoid any misunderstanding here.
This is a piece of software, and it does not
have a nose. Actual smelling in a way that
humans smell something does not happen here,
it is given a molecule structure, and
it makes a prediction based on that. An
AI that has no nose, and yet it can still
smell. Kind of. What a time to be alive!
When I first heard this, I was a little skeptical,
but I had a look at the incredibly thorough
evaluation in the paper, and I found that it
really knows which smells typically appear
together, and can also put these smells on a map.
I think this is an absolutely amazing concept and
with a wonderful execution. As always, the link to
the paper is available in the video description.